comptez pour les femmes amoureuses est
mort hélas jacques higelin et est une
véritable bête de scène tout les clichés
du poète funambule machin tout seul e
celui-ci c'est exactement ça peut être
survoltée est un géant de la chanson
française
son fils arthur ashe racontent les gens
le regardent comme si c'était un demi
dieu et moi je savais que c'était pas un
habitué
les cours
sans compromis jacques higelin était un
drôle d'oiseau adeptes du grand vertige
dans ses chansons aucun sujet n'était
tabou même pas sa propre mort moi je
m'en fous de mourir très honnêtement
c'est pas un truc qui me préoccupe
puisqu'une fois qu'on est mort il ya des
vivants qui pleure on lui donne sans
confession
les années 1970 ont constitué sa période
phare avec des albums comme alertez les
bébés champagne pour tout le monde et
caviar pour les autres des gens qui sont
capables d'improviser comme higelin
pouvait improviser faire des tonnes qui
sur disque dur et trois minutes mais qui
en show en durée 30j en impôts qui font
soit maintenant le puits personne qui
fait ce
[Musique]
insatiable créateur jacques higelin est
souvent venu au québec
enfilant les concerts marathons en 1984
il chante au stade olympique de montréal
lors du concert intitulé magie rose de
diane dufresne
[Musique]
j'en ai beaucoup de gens qui avaient une
amitié entre nous qui durait depuis des
décennies et l'avait rencontrée je
l'avais vu sur scène la première fois le
4 le jour de l'an et a duré toute la
nuit et est certain de la butte un grand
pervers en corporate une comédienne bon
champagne
quant au nom qui vient à présent c'est
inoubliable c'était oublier un été
inoubliable lieu qui porte elle disant
[ __ ] jusqu'à son dernier album réalisé
à l'âge de 75 ans jacques higelin à
manier l'art de raconter comme nul autre
sa folie d'omer et qui sait c'est
peut-être cette image qu'il aurait aimé
qu'on garde de lui
[Musique]
ici où il fait dépouiller mais
radio-canada m'ont rien
oh
[Applaudissements]